monsieur morneau bonjour bonjour on
devait se rencontrer aujourd'hui pour
parler de l' équilibre budgétaire vous
aviez promis en 2015 que le budget
2019-2020 d'aujourd'hui à l'être celui
de l' équilibre budgétaire
pourquoi ne pas avoir respecté cette
promesse à notre avis le chose qu'on a
fait qu'ils étaient très importants au
débaut et nous avons dit aux canadiens
et canadiennes que nous allons faire des
investissements en investissement dont
leur avenir
et ça c'était les choses le plus
important mais en même temps je sais je
sais que d'être responsable au niveau
fiscal est très important et c'est pour
ça que je suis très heureux de dire que
nous pouvons avoir les investissements
comme nous avons expliqué mais en même
temps une diminuation de notre dette
diminuation de notre déficit chaque
année ça veut dire que notre bilan et
mieux aujourd'hui que l'année avant et
l'année vent ça donc c'est une approche
un responsable mais avec les
investissements pour pour les
canadiennes y compris les québécois mais
c'est une promesse brisée vous aviez
promis l'équilibré budgétaire vous ne
l'avez pas respecté bien sûr il y a
toujours les changements dans l'économie
ça c'est très envie que nous y voit bien
les candidats bien tendance économique
depuis 80 3% croissance en 2018 c'est
très bon c'est très bon donc en principe
vous devriez être à l'équilibré
budgétaire revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire je voudrais confessions
récession pour pour nous je crois que
les choses important d'avoir des
investissements parce que de cette façon
on peut continuer vers qu'une bonne
approche pour notre économie ça veut
dire que avec une situation comme nous
avons sûrement c'est pas le temps de
réduire les investissements dans
l'économie avec avec cette approche on
va avoir plus de chômage on va avoir
moins de croissance donc notre proche et
d'être responsable au niveau fiscal ça
veut dire qu une diminuation de notre
déficit chaque année mais pas dans une
façon très vite ça c'est le projet
conservateur je sais qu'avec cette
approche on va avoir des résultats
différents
les réserves des plus mauvaises pour les
canadiens mais si on s'en va en
récession c'est quoi 40 50 60 milliards
de déficit
si les taux d'intérêt se mettent à
augmenter ses plus de 50 milliards de
déficit on n'est pas nouvelle
nous avons à au canada nous avons le
meilleur situation au niveau des dates
dans les g7
c'est une bonne situation c'est clair
que nous devons continuer d'avoir une
bonne situation ça c'est notre proche on
doit avoir aussi une possibilité de
considérer qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
une des filles dans l'économie avec une
bon bilan
nous sommes déjà là j'espère qu'il ya
aussi la possibilité pour la banque du
canada de considérer leur approche dans
une situation difficile
donc on doit toujours considéré les deux
les deux mains par clément le niveau
fiscal nous sommes dans une bonne
situation
nous devons continuer avec cette rappelé
la banque du canada fait son travail
vous votre travail c'est de gérer les
finances publiques
et si on s'en va en récession on s'en va
vers des difficiles de 40 50 60
milliards de dollars
oui mais sûrement je ne veux pas avoir
une récession c'est pour ça que nous
continuons avec notre approche parce que
chacune changements rapides
on va avoir une situation différente
donc il y a deux choix
notre approche est de diminuer à sion
dans une façon responsable
oula proche des conservateurs une
diminuation rapide avec une grand
changement dans notre économie
ça va être le la situation où on peu
près six principes et une récession ça
c'est pas notre vous avez des mesures
assez fondamental pour appuyer les aînés
pour la formation sur l'assurance
médicaments également mais vous attendez
par exemple pour les années ça va
juillet 2020 et pour l'assurance
médicaments ça va 2022
23 pourquoi reporter cela vous allez me
dire vous n'avez qu'à lire les libéraux
pour un deuxième mandat puis on va le
faire c'est un peu ça que vous êtes
finalement non c'est pas ça le chose est
toujours c'est nécessaire d'être
responsable
donc ça veut dire que ça prend du temps
pour faire des choses dans une bonne
façon au niveau de formation
on a une situation
nous avons un nouveau approches pour
améliorer les compétences des
canadiennes quatre semaines avec argent
crédit pour la formation ça c'est très
important mais nous devons assurer que
nous nous allons le faire dans une bonne
façon ça veut dire que ça prend quelques
mois pour assurer qu'on est là bien sûr
au niveau des systèmes des médicaments
ça prend du temps parce que nous le
devons consulter avec les provinces et
les territoires
autant ne pas de la voir faire parce que
c'est un bouton vous parlez de ça
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir fait avant les
coûts des médicaments sont élevées au
canada les gens apprécierait que ça
arrive maintenant pas en 2022 23 oui
mais nous avons commencé nos
investissements au début donc on a
commencé avec la location qui ne les ont
aux enfants on a deuxièmement on a eu
des investissements dans la recherche
troisièmement le fait des
investissements en sciences
tant qu'il ya des choses qu'on a fait on
a pensé que c'était nécessaire d'avoir
un métier pour les avis pour notre
système du médicament
on a dit il y a plus qu'un nom qu'on va
avoir une comédie pour nous aider et
maintenant on a la vie de le comité au
début on va avoir plus d avis et donc ça
prend du temps d'avoir les changements
importants pour l'avenir mais moi je
suis certain qu'on va voir plus de
confiance avec notre approche pour la
formation pour l'offre de logement pour
le système de médicaments pour l'avenir
vous inclinez bien pour la gestion de
l'offre les producteurs ont besoin d'un
soutien parce que vous avez concédé des
parts de marché supplémentaires dans le
lait notamment pour les producteurs
laitiers
vous dites dans le budget vous mettez un
montant mais vous dites ce sera versé au
cours des années des prochaines années
est ce que vous pourriez de moins floue
et plus direct pour les producteurs qui
écoutent ce que je peux dire nous devons
expliquer qu'on veut on va garder le
proche des gouvernements précédents de
20,4 milliards de dollars pour le
secteur mais nous savons que nous devons
avoir les discussions pour exactement
comment on pourrait le faire c'est pour
ça que nous avons expliqué que l'argent
est là on va avoir un cours d'éducation
pour assurer qu'on a nos proches qui va
être bon
on pourrait donc un secteur à quand la
précision des annonces des soutiens
discussions sont en train d'être fait en
ce moment en 2009
je suis pas dans la discrétion mais je
suis certain qu'on va continuer avec
notre proche et nous voulons le faire
aussi tôt que possible en
infrastructures rien de concret pour la
ligne bleue à montréal pour le tramway
de québec pourquoi ces annonces ne
viennent pas plus rapidement
nous avons fait des choses très
important nouveau des investissements en
infrastructures
nous avons travaillé avec avec les
provinces pour assurer que les projets
sur les bons projets les les provinces
on va travailler avec les municipalités
donc il y a une façon de le faire c'est
pas le choix de le gouvernement fédéral
qu'est ce qu'on va faire notre décision
cette année et d'avoir plus d'argent
pour lui une fausse facture 2,2
milliards de dollars pour le pays parce
que nous savons que c'est nécessaire de
considérer aussi dire que possible au
québec ça veut dire que le gouvernement
du québec va travailler avec les
municipalités pour considérer comment ça
pouvait améliorer la situation au québec
et ça c'est quelque chose qui me soit un
cadeau électoral c'est pas un cadeau
nous avons espéré coup vous donnez un
coup mais bien sûr mais il y a quatre
ans nous avons expliqué que nous nous
voulons faire des investissements en
infrastructures
il est en ce moment seront bientôt mais
il ya quatre provinces provinces ontario
au nouveau-brunswick saskatchewan
manitoba qui sont pas avec nous avec les
non-juifs proton donc de cette façon on
peut avoir une proche qui assuré qu'on
va avoir des projets une fausse facture
qui va être là maintenant pour me lire
et la vie des gens et ça c'est notre ça
c'est notre bouffe il m'a finalement à
quel moment la compensation pour les
réfugiés les provinces l'ontario le
québec demandent des compensations
cependant le budget oui deux choses
différentes
on a dans le budget une virgule une
milliards de dollars pour notre système
pour assurer konan
une source de sécurité qu'on a le
processus pour les migrations trop tôt à
mai deuxièmement on parle avec les
provinces en ce moment pour assurer
qu'ils ont assez d'argent pour leur
situation
ça c'est une négociation ça continue
c'est très important mais on a fait
quelque chose différent qui va migrer
notre système et ça c'est très important
en même temps en terminant est-ce que ce
budget aujourd'hui c'est la plateforme
les bases électorales
il y aura des annonces d'ici l'élection
et durant la campagne électorale pour
mettre des chiffres sur tout ce que vous
avez annoncé aujourd'hui ce que je peux
dire notre approche
il ya quatre ans on a commencé avec
notre approche faire des investissements
l'autre partie ont décidé que le
prochain potentiel et cooper austérité
notre proche une version dans les
canadiennes bastion dans la classe
moyenne et des dictionnaires mais on a
fait notre proche avec une diminuation
de notre déficit chaque année avec une
amélioration de notre niveau de chaque
année ça veut dire qu'on peut faire les
choses en même temps
mais la situation des canadiens et
canadiennes y compris les québécoises et
les québécois
et ça fonctionne ça c'est où nous sommes
en ce moment l'économie au québec et
dans une très bonne situation et nous
nous savons que c'est à cause des
québécois bien sûr décide à cause de
légumes allemands de québec mais aussi à
cause de nos investissements dans les
familles nos investissements dans la
classe moyenne pour améliorer leur
situation
merci monsieur moreau merci merci bien
ok